last year I'll tell you how I started
the show on my YouTube channel and last
year I was recruited to play Semi-Pro
volleyball in England and get my
Master's Degree now a lot of you are
like why do you need a master's degree I
didn't I didn't really care about the
degree I picked psychology to study
because I was like oh all the psychology
students in undergrad you guys were
living your best lives you weren't doing
so I was just like I want to pick
this major because it's easy and it's
cheap because let me tell you this
degree has not been cheap because I
failed too many classes and that was
because I failed I didn't fail first
semester I did second semester